foreign
I haven't owned a television in 12 years
but Beck's Ella and I purchased our
first TV congratulations in 12 years we
either congratulations or throw tomatoes
at me I don't know which and I want to
talk about this because there's an
evolution that happened here and I want
to be clear about something if I live by
myself and I don't think it's morally
right or wrong to own a TV obviously but
if I just live by myself a hundred
percent of the time there's no way I
would have home internet or have a TV at
home well why is that because for me
alone when I'm by myself it's too
tempting and it gets in the way of
things I would know I would rather be
doing Reading Writing exercising being
the big three for me it gets in the way
of that
however
I need to also recognize that my own
preferences
I can't map them on to everyone else in
my household like a corrections officer
here's how we're living no matter what
now of course we can have
non-negotiables in a home right
so I I couldn't tolerate a backstarted
smoking in the house or especially if
Ella started smoking
Ella you're nine what are you doing Ella
why do you look so cool
I saw it on the commercial
um so what we decided recently was hey
we want a TV well really back to Owl
want a TV and I can tolerate it and
truth be told I too with the right
boundaries can get value from owning a
TV so what you see right here is our a
picture of our living room now the
number one way that I get value from our
TV now is
98 of the time that we use this TV I use
it to project art and so we don't put
artwork on the walls generally but I do
have art on the TV and so I will find
these YouTube videos in fact we'll put a
link to this particular video in the
show notes over at the minimalists.com
podcast for this episode and
what I do is I have art on the wall and
it just changes regularly and now you
might be looking at this picture and
saying how does he afford a Clara Peters
painting she's a 17th century Dutch
painter obviously yes I knew that but
for TKS
I don't have to buy her art it's simply
there on my wall and it changes out
every five minutes this is how I use the
TV 98 of the time it doesn't mean I'm
better for doing it that way but this is
how I personally get value from it
because I think TVs are ugly especially
there's there on the wall even though we
have it situated there and we we have it
so there's no wires showing or anything
so it's aesthetically okay but putting
art on it actually makes the whole
living room aesthetically pleasing so
here's what I do now every morning I
wake up I'll do the ice bath and then
I'll get a cup of coffee and I'll go sit
on the couch and read and I'll turn on
the TV
and have the art right there and I'll
put zen garden playlist playing in the
background and I will read with the art
on the wall and now I'm not watching TV
I'm not bothered by the TV in fact the
TV is enhancing that experience a couple
other boundaries that really help me
because I have trouble with impulse
control here's one boundary I
don't have a TV in my bedroom I don't
have a tv anywhere else in the house
it's going to distract me the bedroom
for me is meant for two things neither
of which
involve a remote control well now I
think about it that's a that's a
different thing we'll set that aside
also I have some rules around watching
the TV
we
always schedule in advance so we don't
watch the TV haphazardly or impromptu
hey would you like to watch something
tomorrow night great we'll put it on the
calendar and if we're going to binge
watch something here's another boundary
that I have this works for me May or not
may or may not work for you
we never binge more than two episodes
that's binging for us too
so I never watched two days in a row as
well so if we binge something then I I'm
not gonna watch something tomorrow and
then we'll schedule maybe something for
the next day
if we want to schedule it there but that
way I'm making sure the viewing doesn't
get in the way of the things that I know
are more meaningful to me even though
the TV might be more compelling for me
in the moment I recognize that that
impulse I have to Stave off did you
enjoy this Standalone patreon highlight
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free